hello and welcome to this video where
you're going to learn how to code in
javascript with the help of two
really popular millennial games my name
is anya and i'm a software developer and
youtuber who just loves to teach
javascript and react by building
all sorts of online retro and modern
games today i'm going to be focusing on
two
modern classics that's doodle jump
and flappy bird in these two tutorials
you're going to practice over 32 of
javascript's most popular methods
including for each event listener slice
pop push and many more these two
tutorials for those who've already
completed
free code cams fundamental courses in
html css and javascript
as we're not going to be going into the
nitty gritty i'm going to already
you know assume you know the for loop is
you know what a const and let
are if you are unsure of any of those
words that i've just used please go
ahead
and do those fundamentals fast or hey if
you're feeling brave follow along the
more the merrier
i'm gonna go at my natural pace but
please feel free to use the youtube
settings right here
if you want to speed up or slow down it
should be where the little cog is
so yeah go ahead and do that it's pretty
hard to please everyone but hey i try i
also want to make note that this is
going to be the
basic versions of the game okay so we're
not going to be like
leveling up adding levels and the
styling is going to be
super basic i'm doing this because we
want to practice the logic of javascript
and not focus too much on styling that
part is going to be completely up to you
when you do finish your games please do
share them with me i'd love to see what
you've made
how you have been creative how you've
really taken the game and made it your
own
who knows maybe you've like added 10
levels to it i really want to see so
please
do share them with me i'm going to put
my socials right here please tag me and
free code camp
i know we'd both love to see what you
have made okay so what are we waiting
for let's do this
doodle jump exclusively for free code
cam coming up first
okay so first let's talk logic let's
actually figure out what we need to do
to make this game first
so if we look at the game itself you
will see that we need to start off with
five randomly placed platforms so we're
gonna need to make that
we also know they're all equally spaced
apart so
that's something that we're gonna have
to think about equally spaced apart
vertically that is we also have the
doodler himself who automatically lands
wherever the first platform is
okay so we're gonna have to remember
that as well he can't just be landing
wherever when we start the game
otherwise he'll just fall to the bottom
and die we then
also have the platforms moving once the
doodler is at a certain height okay so
they're not always moving it's only if
he moves
past a certain height that's something
else that we're gonna have to remember
now you can also see they are
disappearing if they pass the floor
and then we add a new one to the top
once that happens
so i already know this is going to be
array work we're probably going to be
using
pop or unshift in some way or another
with this array
and of course we have the doula
movements themselves so
that's gonna be a lot of jumping and
event listeners
so yeah you can see he he jumps up and
down if he is on any platform
at any height he also moves left and
right
but stops if he hits the left or right
hand edge
and the game is over if he hits the
floor
we then also need to see the final score
which is actually the amount of
platforms we have jumped over
so we're gonna have to account for that
we're gonna have to store this score
somewhere
okay so now that we have those basics
down here are some of the javascript
methods that we're gonna use for this
project
okay great and now time to set up our
project
okay so to start off here is our project
i've already gone ahead and made some
html boilerplate
where i have linked our app.js file for
our javascript with a script tag
and our style sheet with a link tag
right here
i've also gone ahead and put in a div
and given it the class of grid
this is where all the magic is going to
happen this is where our grid
our doodle jump grid is essentially
going to be
okay so let's actually start off perhaps
by styling this grid up
so let's open up our style sheet
and use dot grid because this is how we
get
classes with the dots we're grabbing the
div
with the class name of grid giving it a
width of
400 pixels a height of 600 pixels
a background color of let's say yellow
for now
a position of relative
okay so i'm going to explain this a
little bit later but we need to give it
a position
of relative if we're going to be dealing
with positions of things in our browser
okay so the next thing we're going to do
is actually grab our doodler
so we haven't made them yet but i'm
going to go ahead and style them up as
if we did
so once again i'm going to give it a
class of doula so
dot doodler and then he's going to be
60 pixels wide so width 60 pixels
a height of 85 pixels a background color
of let's say
red and this time position absolute
ah we need to actually spell doodle
correctly
okay so this is looking good let's go
ahead and make our platforms too
so each platform is going to have a
class of platform
and i'm going to give it a width of 85
pixels
a height of i don't know 15 pixels
and then a background color of
green i think green will be good
i mean this is just temporary for now
i'm also going to give it a position of
absolute
i am using position absolute for the
doula on the platform
to make sure that their position is
absolute inside our grid
whereas the grid itself is going to be
relative to our browser
okay so that's the sort of meaning
behind that
now let's flip over to our app.js file
now the first thing to do because i did
put my
javascript tag in the header is actually
use a document event listener
and pass through dom content loaded okay
so that's the event
essentially what this is saying is that
i only want the contents of this file to
load
only once all the html has been written
let's just get rid of that for now we
don't need it an alternative to this
would be putting your script tag at the
bottom of your html file
both ways are correct this one's just
that little bit more foolproof
okay so first things first let's
actually grab our grid so we can work
with it in this file
i'm going to do so by the getting the
const
grid and using document query selector
so query selector is actually a
javascript method
that allows to pick out elements from my
html
so in this case i am picking out the
class
again dot of grid so i'm picking out
this element right here
next let's grab our doodler so we don't
actually have this in our html file
yet so let's go ahead and create him so
cons doozler i'm going to use document
create element to create a div
so i'm creating a div at the moment
and i'm calling it doodler we haven't
actually placed our doula
in anywhere yet so if you go to your
browser you won't see him
we have just created a div okay now next
let's actually write a function to
create the doodler itself
okay so i'm gonna write function create
doodler
and inside of this i'm actually gonna
grab
our grid which is already made and use a
javascript method called
append child okay so i'm going to put in
something into our grid that's what
child
append child the grid is the parent i'm
putting in a child
into it so i'm going to put the doula
the div we just created called doodler
i'm bringing that into our garage okay
let's go ahead and invoke this to see
what happens and if it has worked
so let's go ahead and do that now uh we
actually need to add some styling to
this
otherwise of course we won't be able to
see it so let's grab that doodler
the constitutional and use classlist ad
to add
the doodler class so this class right
here
to it okay now let's click refresh and
there he is there's our doodler
fantastic that has worked
okay now let's actually get to moving
our dealer around so
i can actually move elements using my
javascript
which is pretty cool i can actually use
javascript
to essentially give css attributes to
elements
i'm going to do this by writing doula
style
and left okay so
if i go ahead and just write the string
50 pixels
and save this file you will see that i
have actually made my element
move 50 pixels or appear to move 50
pixels because essentially all i'm doing
is giving it a left spacing of 50 pixels
great
now i'm actually going to store i don't
want 50. i want to store this 50 as a
variable
so that i can manipulate it later and we
can change it around so
i'm going to do that now i want to say i
don't know doodler left space sure let's
do that do the left space so i'm
replacing the 50
plus px and now all i really need to do
is let doula left space
equal 50. so this is essentially the
same thing
as we wrote before it's exactly the same
thing
cool now let's go ahead
and give it some bottom spacing as well
we do that in the exact same way so get
the doula
use style and bottom and then do the
bottom space plus
pixels and once again at the top let's
define what this
is so let do the bottom space i don't
know
150 pixels see what that looks like
and fantastic so you now see 50
and 150 and it's going from this point
right here okay this corner
that is essentially what we mean
okay great so we've created our doula
this is all looking good
now uh when do i want to create the
doula well i'm gonna actually write
another function
i'm gonna call it function start and
i want our doula to appear if this
function is
invoked okay so let's get rid of this
here because i don't want it creating in
the file
now i'm going to use an if statement and
if is game over which we haven't defined
yet
equals false then
i want to create the doula i'm actually
gonna go ahead and do let this game over
falsie to start with because obviously
when we start the game the game is going
this game over is
false now another neater way of actually
writing is game over false
is actually to get rid of this and just
put a bang
at the beginning okay so if the game is
not over
then we create doodler great
let's invoke this again so this is going
to be
our start function it would be called in
the future to attach a button to this to
make our game start
so it doesn't just start you know when
we load the browser so i'm going to make
a note of this here attach
to a button so we attach this function
to a button but that's something you can
do if you wish
now the next thing i want to happen when
my game starts or whenever we press the
button
is i want to create platforms i'm going
to write function create platforms
and let's go ahead and write this
function so
function create platforms
now essentially in here we're going to
be using a lot of the same logic we did
to create the doula apart from five
times
so hopefully you're gonna be a little
bit more familiar with this
so let's go ahead and do it so for this
i'm actually going to use a for loop
as we need to do this five times as i
said
so for let i equal zero and as long as i
is smaller than five we increment i by
one
okay so this is the syntax for a for
loop
now i could make this a little bit
neater instead of using the five
and actually replace this with a
variable so let's just do that
platform count i guess that sounds
right i'm going to use platform count
for this so let's scroll to the top
and once again let platform
count and i'm going to store the value
5.
this is so we can change it later on as
well
okay so now let's get to writing some
logic
for this i'm actually going to set a
platform
gap to start off with okay because
we need to decide exactly how much space
each platform is going to have
in between each other so let's call this
platform space
now to decide this i'm actually going to
have to look at the height of our grid
so 600 pixels
take that 600 and divide it
by the platform count okay so
that as we know is five so the platform
space
actually let's call it platform gap that
probably makes a lot more space the
platform
gap is now gonna be 600 divided by five
so that's going to be the space if we
choose to add more platforms
this will of course change as well
okay now let's go ahead and start adding
some spacing to all our platforms
so to do this i'm going to make a new
variable called let platform bottom
let new platform bottom
and once again i'm gonna actually give
this new platform bottom
a value of 100 plus i
multiplied by the platform gap okay so
what i'm doing here is using my for loop
in order to increment
the gap space so 100 obviously
when i is zero times platform gap would
be zero
one times the platform gap is going to
be 120
two times the platform gap is going to
be 240 and so on
okay so that's how that's going to work
so
let's go on and do it so i
times plat gap
okay cool okay great now that we have
that down let's go ahead and actually
start making our new platform
so let new platform and i'm actually
going to create a class for this
called new platform okay
and it's going to use things like the
new platform bottom in our for loop
so i'm going to show you how to do this
class
platform and then i'm going to need a
constructor
so constructor to construct our class
that's what a constructor essentially is
now in it as i said i'm going to pass
through the new platform
okay so let's pass it through here as
well and i'm going to use this
to create our new platform so each new
value that i get is going to be passed
through into this class
five times so in each platform
well what makes up a platform let's have
a think about it
each one of them is going to have its
own bottom
so bottom spacing between the five is
all going to be different
and we're going to use new plat bottom
for this we then also
need a left spacing because each
platform
has its own left spacing okay
now we know the grid width is 400 and
the platform width is 85
so we actually go ahead and make sure
that the left spacing is anything
from 315 pixels okay because 400 minus
85 is 315
and the left spacing as we know is from
the left side of the platform
so as long as we get a number from 0 to
315
it will appear in our grid okay so this
left
equals math random this is another
javascript
method if i use math random and multiply
by any number
it will return a random number from 0 to
315.
this is going to be our left spacing for
a platform
now i'm going to do something called
this visual and again use document
create element just like we did with our
doodler
to create a div for each platform
okay so that's looking good now we just
need to add
some styling to it so we're going to
actually store the visual
as the const visual okay this is just we
can use it
so now visual class list add
andy's style of platform i'm doing this
because this visual.classes ad wouldn't
work we need to store it as a variable
first
now once again let's give it some left
spacing so
this style left will be this left plus
the string pixels and visual cell bottom
is of course going to be this bottom
plus pixels this is looking good
i'm really pleased with this so far
okay so the last thing to do as you
might remember from our doula is
actually put this into our grid
once again using append child the
javascript method of pen
child and passing through our newly
created visual
okay
let's see if this has worked moment of
truth
and great you can see all five platforms
randomly
spaced out from the left and evenly
spaced out
from vertical great let's refresh a few
times just to make sure this is working
and fantastic this is looking really
good i'm really pleased
okay so we've created the five uh
platforms but you actually now want to
put them in an array
so that we can work with them in our
project to do this
i'm going to use an array called
platforms so let's actually move to the
top
and make this an empty array now i'm
going to use a javascript method called
push now each time this loops i'm
actually pushing the newly created
platform we've made
into this array okay so i'm literally
going to push it into the platforms
array okay this is how we do it and this
is how push
works so platforms push new platform
i'm going to console log there's just
you can see exactly what's happening and
how we're looping over and how
each time we loop over it gets added so
ah
oops we've obviously misspelled
something here
uh that's right platforms
cool thank you so much console log
for helping us figure that out let's
refresh
and great you will see here that the for
loop is working each time we loop we're
adding
our newly created platform into it and
if we look into these
into our array you will see exactly that
you'll see our platform with the bottom
with a left
so essentially everything that's in our
constructor this is
pretty neat and we can now visually see
all this information
in our console as well awesome
okay now that is done and we can see all
our data and we know everything's
working correctly
let's carry on so we've already got the
jeweler we've created our platforms i
think the next thing
we need to do is why do we focus on
moving the platforms so let's go ahead
and do that
move platforms once again we actually
need to write this function
so let's do that now i'm going to do it
here so
function move
platforms okay
okay now as we discuss we only want to
move the platforms
if the doula is in a certain position so
what this means is let's actually take
the dual of bottom space
because that's how far the doodler is
from the top from the bottom sorry of
our grid
now if the doula is anywhere above 200
the doodle at bottom space is above 200
then and only then we want our platforms
to move
so in the grid you will see here if our
duties anywhere in this space up here
okay then we want our platforms to move
okay so now we actually grab the
platform so our array of platforms
and then for each platform inside this
array so this is how we use the
for each javascript method we go into
the platforms array
we then do for each platform inside
of that array we can essentially call it
whatever we want but i'm going to call
it platform
just for the sake of readability and for
each platform
in that array i want to get the platform
and to its bottom minus
okay so by writing minus equals four i'm
essentially writing platform bottom
equals platform bottom minus four so
this is just a nicer way of writing that
it's a lot it's a lot simpler
now once again we need to get the
platform visual
so let visual equal platform visual
and then visual style bottom equals
platform bottom
plus pixels okay so essentially what we
are doing is making sure
that each of the platforms moves by four
each time
okay let's check it out that has worked
and great that has essentially worked
but because the change is so
small i mean four pixels you probably
can't really see it
now that we're moving each of the
platforms down by
four each time we actually need to put
this move platforms on a set interval
okay so i'm going to put on a set
interval
so this is another javascript method
that will allow us to
invoke the move platforms function so we
pass through a function
and then the time that we want to keep
invoking this function at
okay so now let's go ahead and refresh
that
that should be moving every 30 seconds
30 milliseconds sorry
what is not happening here so we're
getting
our visual from each of the platforms
we're then
getting the style bottom and applying
the new platform bottom to it
ah okay yes it's because we are not
above 200
pixels so if i move it up here 250
tada all our platforms are falling down
because they're on a set interval
moving by four pixels every 30
milliseconds
okay if i move this back to 150 pixels
we are
alert below the 200 mark so nothing's
gonna happen
amazing this is working
okay now that we have the platforms
moving we of course need to make them
disappear
once they hit the bottom and so on but
let's leave that for now let's actually
focus on getting our little doula to
move
so i'm going to write a function called
function jump
jump let's spell that correctly function
jump
okay so our jump function is actually
going to have a lot of
set intervals in here just like we have
the moving platforms we're going to need
it to make
our doula appear like is jumping now one
thing that we didn't use with the other
set interval
is a uh timer id
so a timer id is essentially how we can
stop this clear interval
okay so once we don't want it to keep
moving we can actually clear it with
this id
so i'm going to call it uptime id as you
can already see i've done
and i'm actually going to define it
outside of this function
so i'm going to move it up here and make
it global
so that we can cancel it outside of the
junk function too okay so this is how
you do that you just make a global
okay so uptime id equals set interval
and then we pass through a function
but we don't have a function to pass
through so we're going to write a
function instead
so function and we're going to invoke it
every 30 milliseconds it's the same
format just written a bit differently
this move platforms function is
essentially this function
here okay so same thing just
different format okay so what do we want
to do every 30 milliseconds
in our jump function well i'm going to
get my doodler bottom space
okay and i'm going to plus equals 20 to
it so once again this is essentially
just adding 20
to my doula bottom space each time i'm
also going to
style it so doodle style bottom i'm
going to apply this bottom space
to it using a string as well of pixels
so this is we can
see it as well so we're not only moving
our doula bottom space
we also want to apply it to our element
let's check it out
and whoa there he goes
amazing so he's going up we now have to
probably
make him go down right so let's go ahead
and do that
in here if doula bottom space
is smaller than
let's say 350 for now we want to invoke
a function to
fall okay so now let's get to writing
that for
function let's do it here
function full
okay so once we are falling we actually
want to clear the interval that we
discussed we want to get rid of the
uptime id because we don't want it going
up anymore
so another javascript method called
clear interval will do that and we just
pass through the up timer id
we then want to start another set
interval
so this is going to be just the same as
a jump i'm going to use dime
down down timer id and once again set
interval
and pass through a function and in that
function i want the doula bottom space
to this time go
down by five okay and let's go ahead and
apply it by the styling so doodle start
bottom
doula space plus pics do the bottom
space sorry plus picks
okay so what else do we do i mean it's
gonna be exactly the same right so
what we're doing in here we've got that
great so i'm actually going to make sure
to clear the downtime id when we jump
so each time we go to jump we want to
clear the down timer id
okay and then when we go to four we want
to clear the uptime radius so each of
them canceling each other out
let's make sure to invert the four
function every 30 milliseconds
and let's test it out and whoa
yeah we can see the little element is
jumping and going down once he hits that
350
pixel mark okay so this is looking good
now let's go to stopping him so
if doula bottom space is smaller than or
equal
to zero well we know that's a game over
so
let's actually just go ahead and do it
now so
game over function which we haven't
written yet because of course we're
going to write it now
so function game over now if you think
about it in the game over
we essentially just want to know it's a
game over right so let's console our
game over so we know that it's a game
over
so cool that should be enough to do that
this is obviously just for us developers
this isn't going to show up anywhere
it's just a console log
now we also want to set the is game over
to true
because you know the game is the game is
over
um so that is looking good and we also
want to clear the interval of the uptown
up timer id and the down timer id
even though the technically the uptime
id should be cleared already because
we're going down
i'm just going to do it here you know as
a default just as a safe sort of
practice
okay cool and there he goes
and our console log is printing game
over and we're no longer moving down
because the down timer id is cleared
fantastic
let's just try again this is looking
great
but as you can see we need to do a lot
more right we're not even done
we don't want our doodle jumper to just
be
okay so this is all looking great i'm
really pleased with how this is all
looking we've got our game over we've
got our platforms moving
one thing we did mention is that we
actually need our doula to start off
on our platform right so we don't want
them just appearing anywhere
but not just any platform our first
platform
so we can easily do that let's move over
to our create
doodler function
now in here doula style left
now we don't actually want him
just going anywhere so i'm going to get
the doodle less space
and assign it our first platform so
we're going into our platforms array
we're in the first item so we do this by
passing through a zero
into our array and we're getting the
left of that platform so let's have a
look at it
here so if you look here i'm going into
our platforms
and then going into the first platform
and then grabbing the left so now
it's going to be the same let's check it
out
so let's go ahead and see what this
looks like ah
and an error message why is there an
error message
all we're doing is going into the
platforms aha it's because we actually
make the platform after
we try to get the platform so we can
easily solve that let's just solve
this by moving these two functions
around so we're going to create the
platforms first
and then create our doodle jumper okay
because we want to create the four
or five platforms first so we can then
take the first platform
once again thank you error log okay now
let's carry on
okay so now
what else do we need to tackle well i
think we need to actually
get our doodle jumper moving when we
control our keyboard so i'm going to do
this with a function called control
in this control function i'm actually
gonna essentially link up the keys on
our keyboard
in order to use them and whenever we
press the keys that we want a function
will get invoked
so i do this like this if e for event
key equals arrow left as a string
so ease for event we actually need to
pass this into our function
if the key that we press is the arrow
left
on our keyboard then we want to move
left
right so we don't have a move left
function yet so i'm just going to put
some pseudo code in here
else if e key equals arrow
right so the string arrow right this
time then
well you guessed it i want to move right
so once again i'm just going to put a
placeholder hole that placeholder here
else if e key equals arrow
up well i essentially just want to
straighten out
because i don't want to move left or
right anymore so
i'm going to just put move straight
sure move straight function
do we want to write this here no let's
let's comment it out for now and put it
as a placeholder
okay this is looking good um
what should we tackle first
so again we want to be able to move
our doodle jumper
before we do anything let's actually set
ourselves
some variables so i'm going to put let
is jumping equals true
because if we if you remember
we only want to be able to jump again
if his jumping is false okay because
we don't want him to be like mid-jumping
we don't want to jump and jump again if
he's already mid-jump
and then in the jump once we are jumping
we want his jumping to be true
okay that makes sense right when we're
jumping is jumping is true
and when we're falling well you guessed
it as jumping is false
so now we have this being stored so we
always know if he is jumping or he's not
jumping and we can use this in our
project
great okay i think we should probably
tackle
i think let's tackle if the doodle
jumper is actually on a platform so
we're essentially checking up for
collision
so we're gonna do this in the fall
because we don't care if he's jumping if
he's jumping he'd go through the
platforms
we only care if he's falling and if he
falls onto a platform we want him to
essentially jump again
so let's do this by grabbing our
platforms array
and for each platform so for each item
in our platform's array
if the doula bottom space
so from the bottom is bigger than or
equal to the platform bottom
and the doula bottom space is smaller
than or equal to the platform bottom so
essentially we're going
we're making we're checking if the doula
bottom space is in between that 15
pixels
in between so we're checking if it's in
the platform
right so you can see here height 15
and that's why we are adding that 15
because we are checking if he's at the
bottom of the platform but plus 15.
now we also need to check for if the do
the left space
so we need the first statement to be
true and the second mutual
second statement to be true and now this
statement to be true
so do the less base plus 60 so we're
going from the left and plus 60
because that's the width of our doula
and then we are checking if that
is smaller than or equal to platform
left
okay so once again
we are getting the do the less space
we're adding the width of the doula to
it
and whatever that number is is smaller
than the platform left
means it's not on the platform okay he's
to the left of the platform somewhere
so we need that to be true and we also
need to get the do the less space
now this time we actually need to check
that this is smaller than or equal to
the platform left space
but this time plus the platform's width
okay so we're essentially making sure
that the delay is not anywhere on the
right side
of the of the platform so all of these
four things need to be true
in order for a collision to happen so we
need to make sure that
the doula is not in here or not in there
and he's also in that little platform
space cool
now we just need to check for one final
thing and that is
that he is not jumping okay
so just this is sort of like i guess
safety blanket because we are falling so
he should technically not be jumping but
you know just to like fool proof this
whole thing
great let's actually also get a
console.log going just to check
that we have met all of those criteria
and we should get a console saying
landed
and then once he has landed we want him
to jump again
so let's put that function here and
invoke it so if all those things are
true and that is statement
we want to print landed and jump again
so bang there we go landed bang and we
are jumping
awesome okay this is looking good there
is a floor however
i don't know if you can see it but our
jump only goes to a certain height
this is because we hard coded the max
height that we can jump to
okay so at any point we'll never ever
jump higher than this okay not even c
not even if we get like a platform
that's close to that it just won't
happen
this is because we need to reset our
starting point of when we are jumping
because at the moment we're simply
jumping a certain amount so let's do it
now
so do the bottom space is 150 i'm
actually going to make another variable
called let's start point equal
and to start off with it's actually
going to be 150
so i can actually get the do the bottom
space and
assign it the start point for when we
start jumping so that's what we're
writing here
essentially okay so now let's use this
to reset
essentially our jumping point each time
so once again i'm going to do this here
so i'm going to get the start point
and whatever the doula bottom space is
at this time
i'm going to make it the start point
okay so i'm overwriting
150. so if we're on a platform then we
can overwrite the start point
and store it as start point so we can
use it globally so our start point is
only
now changing okay
so there's gonna be our new start point
for jumping i'll do the bottom space
it's always gonna be moving continuously
moving because we're gonna track
wherever the jeweler is
but our start point is gonna change
okay so now if doula bottom space
is smaller than and we need to change
this 350
we're going to get our start point so
remember at the start it's 150
plus 200 so essentially we're not
changing anything too much here
but as soon as we land on a platform
that number's going to change
so let's see if that has worked
woo okay and there we go we have now
fixed our problem okay
only a few more things to do and that is
actually
write our move left function move right
function and move straight function
let's start off with our move left
function so
here we go function move left
now what happens when we move left well
essentially
it's very similar to the jumping but
we're going to be changing the
doula space left instead so i'm actually
going to write a new variable
let is going left let's actually also
set this at the bottom so it is going
left is false
because that's what we are starting with
i'm actually going to go ahead and write
let is going right false as well because
i know i'm going to use that later on
so it is going left when we are moving
left
i want to change this to true okay i'm
going to store that globally
now i'm also going to start a left timer
id so once again it's a set interval
left timer id equals set interval and
pass it through a function
once again i'm going to store this left
timer id globally and this right time id
globally so we can access it and other
functions
so that is now done cool now what do we
want to happen
let's move on equals what do we want to
happen in here
well a few things we need to get
the doodler to move so let's go and do
the left space
and this time minus five from it
or yeah minus five from it and then we
need to actually
show this in our browser so i'm gonna
use doula style left
and then do the left space one of the
new dead doula
spaces plus pixels okay
and then i i want to invoke this uh set
interval every 30 milliseconds
so that is looking good now
okay now we just need to hook up our
control
function so the move left is in the
control function
i'm going to do this in the start
function and use document and add
event listener and pass through control
but also the event of
key up so now each time we
essentially press our key we can
invoke this control function which will
invoke our move left function
and if we move our or click sorry our
arrow left button our keyboard
we will move left and great this is
working perfectly
now one thing that isn't going well is
that our doula is actually going off the
left off our grid we need to stop this
so if do the left space is bigger than
or equal
to zero and only if this is true then
we can make our doula move otherwise we
move right
let's get to writing our function for
move right
again it's going to be very similar to
move left is going right
equals true okay now
let write timer id equal
set interval and then a function which
makes sure that if the doula left space
this time is
smaller than or equal to the width of
the grid
so it's smaller than or equal to what is
it again
400 okay and then we need to actually
minus the
doula width so 400 minus the doula width
so 340
okay so if that statement is true and
only if that statement is true
we get the doula left space and this
time let's add five to it
and once again let's apply this to the
styling so
doodler left sorry doula style left and
the doodle left space
cool don't forget to add the string of
pixels
so now we just need to make sure
to account for if it is so if it is then
we move left
and let's invoke this every 30
milliseconds great this is
looking good
okay shall we test it out
let's actually put this back here so
move right and invert the function
okay so now if you press the right arrow
so let's go ahead and do that
whoa what the hell is happening why is
it going so fast
okay what have we done
that's strange it's also sort of like
flinching because it can't decide
whether to go left or right that's
because we haven't cleared the interval
so let's do that first function move
left if
is going right we clear the interval
right time right d
and we set is going right to false okay
so when we're moving left we need to
clear the right time id
and make sure that we're not going right
anymore let's do the same for move left
so
if is going left well we need to
clear interval
left timer id and make sure that is
going left is false
okay great that should definitely stop
the twitching
um let's refresh that
boom i mean it's still going really fast
i don't know why that is but at least
it's not twitching anymore
boom why is that doing that
ah it's because we're putting 50 we need
five great
typo okay and that's much better
cool we now have a little doula whacking
off
each side we now need to actually allow
it to straighten up if we want to right
so we don't always want it to going
from left to right from left to right we
need like an out
so for this let's focus on the move
straight
so function moves straight and i'm
simply just going to clear
everything so i'm going to put is going
right it's false
it's going left is false um
what else we need to do clear the id so
clear interval
right timer id and clear interval
left timer id okay
it's looking good
cool let's test this out again and we've
done it
this is looking better and better each
time
it's still glitching when we get a game
over i mean we just need to do some more
interval clearing but this is looking
good
okay now i think let's focus on
actually removing the platforms and
adding new ones so that's gonna be fun
that's gonna be some fun array work
let's do this in the function move
platform
if the platform bottom this time is
smaller than let's say
10 so you're really at the bottom of the
grid not exactly the bottom but you're
in the last like
slice that 10 pixel slice if the
platform if any of the platforms in fact
are there
we need to get rid of the first platform
in the array
okay so let first platform let's define
it
let's grab our platforms array go
into it so we're going into our opening
of our array we're in first item
and we're getting as visual okay so now
let first platform is defined classlist
i'm going to remove the class of
platform
from it so i'm removing the cluster
platform on the first
item this is so we can visually not see
it anymore
okay now we actually need to also remove
the array
i'm going to do this by grabbing the
platforms array and using
shift so shift will do that it will get
rid of the first
item it's another javascript method that
will get rid of the first item of an
array
so now if we console our platforms let's
see if that has worked
and great you will see here that the
platform array is getting shorter and
shorter each time
let's just test out again i'm just
really happy with how this is looking
and obviously it's quite cool to see our
array going down by one each time
okay so we're getting rid of the first
one let's go ahead and actually
add a new platform as well so
i'm gonna use let's
new platform and what we need to do is
actually use the class again so let new
platform
new platform but the class of new
platform this time
so this is the class of new platform now
we need to pass something through
into our cluster platform member and
that's our bottom space
well because we know that our grid is
600 pixels high
let's pass through just a hard-coded 600
so that will mean that our new platform
will appear at the top of our grid
okay this is looking good and now we
actually need to add that to the
end of our array so i'm going to do that
again with another javascript method i'm
going to grab
our platforms array use push and then
pass through this new
platform okay let's test it out
and great this is looking good you will
see our new platforms being created
each time a platform disappears i mean
i'm really proud
of this i think this is fantastic um
let's carry on okay so the one thing i
did want to do is get rid of that
glitchiness right
so if this this is definitely to do with
the intervals
let's head over to our game over
function and clear the intervals of left
time right d
and right timer id to stop that
glitching so clear interval
yeah pass that through and clear
interval
again that will 100
100 stop any glitching happening
okay so let's test that out
i mean it's just so fun to play um but
yeah come on let's let's actually do
some testing it's actually quite hard to
get at the bottom
maybe i should increase the hardness
settings of this
okay let's do it now okay put that to
20 and put that to a 20. i think that
should make it harder
okay i think it just makes just means
everything's going to move faster right
so ah
it's still glitching why is this
happening
hmm
okay this is really weird but you know
what let's just get rid of it right
because it's game over we don't want it
there anyway
so i'm going to show you something cool
and a cool way to get rid of all the
children of a parent so i'm essentially
going to get rid of anything in the grid
i'm going to use wild to do this so
while
grid first child this essentially means
if this is true
so if a group if the first child of the
grid exists
then we continue to remove the
grid's first child okay so this is
essentially a loop
while this is true remove the first
child if there's another first child
remove the first child
until we have zero children in there
okay so that's cool
i'm also gonna actually display the
score here so i'm gonna use grid and
then
in html and then score
so let's actually set that globally to
let score equal
zero now all we need to do is define
where we actually add a score
well i think it would probably make
sense to add a score you know like as
soon as we get rid of a platform
so score plus plus and there we go
now that means that we are storing a
score
so once we actually let's die and let's
see what happens
you should see all the elements
disappear and then yep
and great you will now see it that has
worked
it's tiny but it has worked that's just
styling
so cool let's go ahead and i'm gonna do
it now with you quickly
so inside our grid i'm actually going to
add
font size and let's make it huge right
let's make it like 200 pixels
cool text align as well to make it in
the center
and center okay
so now when we die
let's make our little guy die
of course like this is still really
basic i really do want you to like
go wild with the styling i'm gonna style
it myself and put on my github so feel
free to take it if you want but
obviously it's like it's much better to
do it yourself and
really give it that ah and there we go
22 amazing my score was 22
i passed one two platforms and we can
now see an average
one huh okay that's it thank you so much
for watching
i hope this was really useful i really
enjoyed making this with you and as i
said
please do share your finished games with
me i'd love to see how you styled it
this is something i made earlier this is
something i made you're more than
welcome to it but again
please do try it try make your own
thanks so much again for watching if you
enjoyed this video please do like and
subscribe to my channel
i'd love to uh have you there and please
do comment on any other sort of projects
you'd like me
to make or you'd like to see from me or
if there's some like
concepts that you don't understand i'm
more than happy to explain them
to you thanks so much again and i'll see
you soon
for those of you who have never played
flappy bird before it's a
simple game in which you as the player
so the little bird
have to navigate obstacles which are
little pipes
actually coming down this way in this
way so there's like two pipes you have
to get navigate through them
but you also have gravity trying to pull
you down so you
can't hit the pipes and you can't hit
the floor otherwise it's a game over
so now that that's done let's do it
flappy bird
okay so make sure we have linked up our
javascript file with our script tag
and the style sheet with the link tag
now we create a game container div so
give a div the class
container now our game container is
going to contain a
div with the class of sky and a div with
a glass of ground
in the sky div i'm going to hard code
our bird
so add a div with a class of bird in it
great now go ahead and save this file
and flip to your style sheet
now styling we're going to do this by
picking out the class of our game
container so let's do that first
we tell our file to class by this dot
before the name
now how big do we want our game
container to be well let's give it a
high of let's say
730 pixels and a width of 500 pixels
i am also going to give it a position of
absolute
this means the element is positioned
relative
to its positioned ancestor element in
layman terms this means whatever parent
div this div is in
we will position it based on the parents
dimensions and position
now let's grab these sky we will give it
a background color of light blue for now
just so we can play around with it we
can replace this with an image later
let's also give it a width of 500 pixels
so it fits in our game container exactly
let's also give it a height of 580
pixels
and a position of absolute relative to
the game container it is in
now let's pick out the ground once again
let's pick a color
so brown this time give it a width so it
fits exactly in our game container
a height that is 730 pixels
minus 580 pixels so the height of our
sky
so it fits in the remaining space of our
game container
let's also not forget to give it a
position of absolute
once again this is relative to the game
container because that is the parent
element
okay let's flip over to our browser see
what this looks like
ah it appears that light blue is not a
color so let's
go back and make this blue
you will see here that we have all the
elements here
so you will also see here that they will
collect on the top left corner
we need to fix this so the ground
appears below the sky
we can do this in our css file using a
property called top
by writing top we are saying that we
want to give spacing between the top of
the element
and the top of the parent element the
ground is in as we want the ground
below the sky we simply put the height
of the sky
so 580 pixels like this let's see what
this looks like now that should be below
and it does great let's also just zoom
out a bit so we can see what we are
doing
okay now i'm also going to go ahead and
style our bird so let's grab the bird
class give it a background color of
yellow so we can see it against the blue
background now once again a position of
absolute
a height of 45 pixels and a width of
let's say 60 pixels
we are now ready to start applying logic
to our elements
so let's go ahead and flip to our
javascript file in order to pick out
elements to work with now
as we put our script tag here we need to
wait for all our html to load before
reading any javascript
we do this by using a dom event listener
so we grab the document
and add a javascript method of add event
listener to it
now we pass through the dom content
loaded event
and need a function so this is how event
listeners work we pass through an event
and then a function from now on all our
javascript will be between
these two parentheses and curly braces
we need to pick out our first element
let's get to picking our bar let's pick
the badge
we do this by grabbing the document
using a javascript method of query
selector
and then passing through a string of bad
not forgetting the dot as it's a class
name we are looking for
let's also save this as the conspired so
we can use it again and again in our
javascript
let's also do the same for the game
container
so get our document use our query
selector
then pass through the class name of game
container
let's save this as the constant i don't
know game display
and once again for the ground so
constrain equals document query selector
and pass through the class name of
ground
now the first thing we're going to do is
move our bird to the bottom-ish
center of our sky of our sky div
as that is what it sits in right in the
sky div
so right there in the middle bottom
we're going to do this by adding space
between the sky's
left side and the bird's left side let's
say by
220 pixels so let's set a constant that
will vary
so let bad left equal 220
and let's do the same for the bottom of
the sky div
and the bottom of the bad element so
let's say
100 pixels we want between those two
now that we have this declared let's
write a function to apply these pixel
changes to the styling of our bird
element
let's write a function called start game
now by grabbing the bird element and
using a method of style and bottom
i'm going to add this new bird bottom
value to it
and using plus px and strings i'm saying
add 100 pixels to the bottom of our bird
element
relative to the sky div it is in let's
go ahead and invoke the start game
function
and have a look what this looks like and
great you will see
our bird bottom we have added 100 pixels
to that that looks cool let's go ahead
and do the left side
so we want to add spacing between the
left side of the wall remember left side
of the sky grid
and the left side of our bed
so once again let's grab the bird
element
get the style and
left and assign bud left so about left
is 220
and add the string of pixels
start and left is actually javascript
methods i'm not making that up
and let's refresh and great our bird is
now in the position that we want
let's carry on now as we know we want
the bird to move down with gravity
because the bird starts dropping
as soon as this game is started so let's
get gravity
and set it as two as a variable so let
gravity equal two
now let's grab our bottom and each time
we invoke this function we wanna minus
gravity from the bird bottom so we're
changing the bird bottom variable
essentially to minus two each time
this function is being invoked now as
you see it's only movement once we won't
actually put this on an interval because
we wanted to
execute over and over again appearing
the bus be dropping
so i'm going to use set interval this is
a javascript method called set interval
to do this
the set interval works by passing
through a function
and a time so let's put 20 milliseconds
so i want this to invoke every 20
milliseconds
i want the start gain function to invoke
every 20 milliseconds if i assign this
to
a variable so let time id i can actually
stop this set interval from running
i will do this by passing it through
another javascript method called clear
interval
so as you can see here i am passing time
id through clear interval
this will essentially stop this
particular set interval
from running let's get rid of this now
as we don't need it and see if this has
worked
okay great that looks perfect
let's carry on okay now let's get about
to jump so as we know we need about to
jump
if we press a button we want it to
actually go up and sort of fight against
the gravity
i'm going to do this in a function
called jump so function jump
let's grab that by getting the bird
element star bottom
bad bottom plus pixels now
i'm going to grab the bad one again and
actually add
50 to it before passing it through to
style our badge
this means that each time we invoke the
jump function i am adding
50 pixels to whatever bad bottom is
before
styling our bird with this new bad
bottom
okay now using an event listener i'm
going to grab document
and using the javascript method of add
event listener so remember about event
listeners we need to pass through two
things
the event in this case is going to be
key up
actually no key up so each time your
finger leaves a key on the keyboard
i want to invoke the jump function
let's see if that has worked and great
that looks good i am happy to carry on
let's just console log the bird position
at all times to the bird bottom
just so we can see in our console look
what's happening let's inspect the page
open it up
and great you will now see our bad
bottom at
all times whenever we jump
as you can see here we're sort of
reaching 500 we don't really want about
to go off the grid
of the top so we can actually stop this
so
yeah that looks around 500 i guess
essentially i guess it would be 100
we're in a 580 box so 480
i think that's around 480 we should make
the bad stop
so if bad bottom is smaller than so this
means smaller than
and i guess yeah 580 pixels minus the
100 we started so 480 pixels
and only if this is true we want to jump
okay so as long as bad bottom is under
480
we can keep jumping and okay well oh
that's weird
maybe we should increase that bit
because you can actually go a little bit
further can't it
let's make 500. so as long as bird
bottom is smaller than 500
we can add 50 to the bed bottom to make
it appear to be jumping
and great this looks great
perfect i am really happy with how this
is working out
let's perhaps continue by making sure
that not just
any key on our keyboard is a jump but
specifically the space bar will invoke a
jump
so i'm going to write a function called
control and password e for event
so this e is actually short for event
now
using e if e key code so key code as a
javascript method
deeply equals the number 32
so number 32 is actually the key code
for your space bar
so if we press the keyword 32 so the
space bar
then we jump so now let's go ahead and
replace the event listener
to execute the control function which
then controls the jump function
now have a go yourself we are jumping we
are jumping but we are only jumping if
we press the space bar not any other key
on our keyboard
that's pretty cool you can link it up to
whatever key you like i've just chosen
the space
bar please do google kiko's on the
internet
there's loads of resources which you
choose from keycode.info is a good one
i'll share it with you below
okay now that we've done that let's get
to generating obstacles
so i'm going to do this in a function
called generate obstacle
i'm actually going to use a javascript
method called create
element to do this so by grabbing the
document
i'm going to use a javascript method
called create element and pass through
into it the string of div okay so from
now on this is how you create
divs i'm going to save this as const
obstacle so we can use it later in our
javascript
i'm now going to grab the obscure and
using classlist add
another javascript method i'm going to
add the class of obstacle
to this div we haven't actually written
this styling yet so let's flip over to
our style sheet
and give our obstacles some styling so
dot obstacle for class
background color let's go green for now
we can change this later
width i'm going to say 60 pixels height
300 pixels let's say
position absolute as always so it's
absolute we haven't actually put this
div
in anyway yet but we will be so i'm
going to show you how to do this now
let's flip back to our app.js file
now grabbing the game display to the
game container i'm saying i want to grab
this div right here so the div class
game container
now using a method so let's grab that
game display now so that's the game
container
i want to put in my obstacle into this
i'm going to do this with the pen child
this is a javascript method append child
and pass through
the created obstacle we just made by
doing this
i am literally putting in a div into the
game container
it's pretty cool right i'm putting it in
with sky and ground
let's invoke this function to see if
this has worked
so press save refresh and great
we have now put an obstacle into our
grid
amazing now let's actually position it
to where we want
so we've done this before we grab the
element
we then use style and left to give it
a i guess padding from the left side of
the sky container to the left side of
our obstacle
i'm going to set a variable obstacle
left let's declare it up here so let
obstacle
left equal 500 pixels that's the width
of our grid
so then it should appear in the right
place if we said it's 500
i'm actually also going to give it
obstacle bottom as well so we want it to
appear i guess
above our ground which is 150 pixels
tall as we can see here
so as a reminder what i am doing is
positioning
our obstacle to be 150 pixels so
i guess the height of the ground so it
appears to be above the ground
so let obstacle bottom equal 150
great this is looking good now let's
grab the obstacle
element and use style bottom
to add the obstacle button passing
through this so this is we're just
passing 150
150 pixels and fantastic
this is exactly where we wanted our
obstacle to be everything is looking
great
500 pixels and then 150 pixels
fantastic i think we are ready to
carry on right hopefully you understand
this by now
and how the left and bottom work
okay now the next thing we want to do
whenever we generate
a obstacle we want to let it generate a
random height
okay we don't want all the obstacles
coming in at the same height i'm going
to do this by generating random numbers
and passing them through into our
obstacle bottom
so let random height i'm going to set a
variable of random height
equals i'm going to use math random
this is a javascript method and if it's
multiplied by
any number we get any number from 1 to
that number
so let's say i don't know 60
that should be fine so math random
multiplied by 60 will give us a number
one to 60 now
that's our random height so i can get i
don't know 5 30 45 whatever number
coming out of this i have chosen 60 as i
want an obstacle to appear below this
ground line
but quite a bit under it okay so there's
150
the ground is 150 high and i've chosen
to make our obstacle pier 60 from the
ground to 60 from the game
now that we have our random height i'm
going to assign it to obstacle bottom
now each time we refresh the page you
will see what i mean
so our obstacle is generating at random
height from 0 to 60
each time by 0 to 60 i mean from the
bottom of our game grid
now let's get our obstacle moving from
right to left
in the generate obstacle function i'm
going to write another function called
move obstacle
in it i'm going to get our obstacle left
and minus 2 from that variable each time
we execute this
so sort of like we moved our flappy bird
we are now going to move our obstacle
left by 2 visually each time the move
optical function
is invoked so again we need to put this
on a timer
as we don't want this function invoking
just once we want it to keep invoking
until we stop it
so again let time id we can set it as
let him id as the other timer id
is outside of the scope of this function
so it's fine
now set interval let's use the set
interval method and pass through a
function
so this times we move obstacle and let's
choose to invoke it
i don't know every 20 milliseconds again
just so it's consistent
so 20. great
okay now that we have done that we need
to grab the obstacle
use style and left and reassign the
obstacle left to it
so it actually affects our obstacle
element let's save this file
and check it out and awesome it's moving
amazing i love how it moves this looks
fantastic
we now need to stop our element once it
hits the left hand side right we want to
make it disappear
we need to stop it and make it disappear
let's do that again
in our move optical function so
if obstacle left deeply equals zero
okay because that is zero position zero
right here
if it does deeply equal zero
actually let's have a look at this so
maybe we actually want the obstacle to
view when it's minus 50 as we want the
whole obstacle to be out of view
if we stopped at zero it would sort of
disappear but you'd still see it
does that make sense so we want it to be
when it's outside of view
and since the obstacle width is 60
pixels isn't it let's check this
that's actually yeah okay yeah it's 60
so let's change it from 50 to 60.
okay so if obstacle left db equals 60
we clear interval and we pass through
the timer id
we stop this set interval from excusing
we then grab our game display and just
like we used a pen child we remove
child obstacle so we pass through the
obstacle to remove it
okay let's see if that has worked
and great our obstacle has now
disappeared and stopped fantastic
now that we have done this let's move on
to actually generating new obstacles
once our obstacle has gone off the grid
i'm going to do this by putting a
function that we've actually already
written
so the generate obstacle function on
another timing event called set
timeout so set timeout
once again we pass through the function
so generate obstacle
and this time we pass through a time so
this time means after this amount of
time has passed
then we want to execute the function
generate obstacle
okay so let's say that we want to
execute this function every three
seconds
so i think three seconds is about enough
time so we pass through
three thousand three thousand
milliseconds set timeout general
obstacle three thousand milliseconds
okay so generate obstacle let's save
one two three great
we now have random obstacles generating
at random heights
every three seconds fantastic this is
all looking good so far
now let's actually get the game to stop
if the bird reaches the bottom
of our sky grid so once again because
the bird is
in the sky grid if bad bottom equals
zero it means it's at the bottom of the
sky grid
what do we want to happen well we want
the game to finish right so let's write
a function called game over
so function game over
in it let's decide that we want to clear
the interval
start game do you know what let's for
clarity let's actually change this so
maybe make it i don't know
game timer id okay
just so we don't get confused game timer
id so we want to clear the start game
function from running
we want to then set a variable that is
game up to true
let's actually go ahead and declare this
here so as default is game over it's
false obviously because
we want to start off with it being true
we can play the game
that looks good okay what else do we do
on a game over
well we actually want to stop our
key spacebar key from working so using
document and remove event listeners time
we pass through the key up and control
this is how we remove events
so now if a game is over and you press
your
key space bar nothing will happen let's
go ahead and try that
and yeah perfect that works
now let's get to writing what happens if
our bird
is in the same location as an obstacle
so essentially if we collide with the
obstacle okay
so i'm going to write this like this and
tell you a little bit why
so if obstacle left is larger than 200
meaning that it's not in the last 200
pixels of its travels
and obstacle left is smaller than 280
okay so it's like literally in
the middle of our grid essentially and
our
bird left deeply equals 220
in the position of 220 as it is all the
time anyway maybe this is relevant
then we have a game over okay so let's
check this out
okay so as you can see our game is
stopping our bat is no longer moving
it's not dropping down
our space bar does not work anymore
great and we're getting game over
show up in our console fantastic i know
the obstacle's still moving we need to
fix that
we can actually do this by using if and
then
passing through is game over but bang by
putting bang it's game over i'm
essentially saying
if this game over is not true so if this
is
false if it's game move is false
so the game carries on then we can
generate new obstacles every three
milliseconds
however if this is true and it is a game
over
then we won't generate new obstacles on
the set timeout
get it let's see if that has worked
okay it has worked we are not generating
new obstacles
however we're generating one obstacle
do you see that so it was like one got
generated then we stopped generating new
ones but it was too late for the other
one
how do we solve this okay
perhaps i know okay so obviously one
more
obstacle is being generated we can
actually say we can actually just not
add a class to it
so once again if bang is game over
so if the game is not over so if this
is false then we can add a class of
obstacle
to the obstacle but only if the game is
not over okay let's see if our little
fix has
worked okay great
now once there is a game over there are
no more obstacles being generated
we are that much closer to what we want
the last thing we need to do is actually
stop our obstacle from moving so that
green one right we actually want to stop
when it collides with the bird
let's also do that here
so if any of the above is true
we get a game over and we also clear our
time id
so we stop the move obstacle from moving
so we'll let's clear that time 82
right here let's save and now ah oops
and now when the bird and obstacle
collide
both stop amazing
now you will see here that we have not
written a rule to allow a butter to fly
over the obstacle we're simply saying if
the two are aligned vertically then the
game is over
let's fix this so again in here let's
write more rules
so once again here let's write more
rules so this time if bad bottom
is smaller than obstacle bottom
plus let's just play around with some
pixels here so 190 let's see if that
works
okay that's nearly there let's make a
bit smaller so
let's go ahead and try 160 i just want
to see what looks the best
really what makes it look like the most
realistic
so that looks okay actually let's make
it a tiny bit smaller again
155 actually 153
let's make it 153.
okay that looks perfect i'm happy to
carry
on so bad bottom as long as bad bottom
is smaller than obstacle bottoms
whatever obstacle bottoms at the time
it'll be a number from zero to 60
plus 153 and that should work great
i'm actually going to go ahead and show
you how to make these pipes looks like
actual pipes
so if we head over to my github
where i've stored these items for you
kindly please feel free to take them
or you can of course make your own
that's a lot more fun so
if you go over to my repo called flappy
birds
you will find the pipe just go ahead and
download it
and then perhaps you need to write so
i'm going to right click and save
image save image as and just save it to
my download so
save now i'm just going to import it by
dragging it in
so this is quite easy when you use vs
code i'm just going to drag it into my
project
cool so now you'll see my pipe okay i'm
going to replace the background
color here background image and the url
that is
the url of my pipe in the project
so it's actually the root of my project
so i don't need to do much just pass
through the name
oops i put in the wrong place let's put
it in the root of my project
i don't know why i put in an open editor
okay
let's save and let's see how that has
worked
amazing here's our pipe
this looks great i'm happy to carry on
now i'm actually going to shoot
something cool we're going to actually
do the top obstacle
so i'm just going to copy paste this
here i'm going to rename it as top
obstacle so it's the same thing really
however
i'm going to use a property called
transform
and pass through the degrees i want to
transform it by
so to make it look upside down i'm going
to pass through
180 degrees so rotate
180 degrees
cool now this part will be easy
essentially each time we have anything
to do with obstacle we need to do the
same for top obstacle
okay so here you see how we create a
element div
let's do the same but call it top
obstacle so top up score equals document
create element
and then password div so we're creating
a div and storing is top obstacle this
time
now let's grab the game's display and
append it
using a pen child top obstacle we're
passing with the top
top obstacle into our game this time
if there is not a game over so if the
game is running
we also want to add the class of
obstacle or top obstacle
to our obstacle and then of course we
want to
as the obstacles are moving the same
time we just use obstacle left so
top obstacle style left equals obstacle
left just to make sure they're both
moving at the exact same time use the
same variable
and top obstacle style bottom now again
we'll use the same variable so
bottom optical bottom plus a gap
let's set this gap at something i don't
know 400 pixels
so now each time the top of the score
will have a gap of 400 pixels between
it and the bottom obstacle cool ah oops
we need to change that top obstacle too
i forgot
okay let's save this ah amazing
we're getting the top of school it's not
moving yet
but that's fine we'll fix that at least
it's appearing there
with a 400 pixel gap
i'm gonna make this gap bigger let's
make it i don't know 430 pixels
i'm sure that'll be fine cool let's
carry on now let's just see if this
works okay yeah that's better that's
much better actually
now the reason our top obstacle is not
moving
is because we actually forget to assign
it the obstacle left
variable so once again total score style
left
equals obstacle level pixels while we
are here let's actually go ahead and
remove the top obstacle once it hits
the left hand side too ah i misspelled
left
and great we now have both obstacles
moving along now we need to also write
some rules that is a game over if the
bad hits the top obstacle
let's do that once again in here
this time i'm going to write i'm going
to open up some brackets
okay and put this around the brackets so
what i'm saying here is that
if bad bottom is smaller than obstacle
bottom plus 153
or the bad bottom is bigger
than the obstacle bottom
plus the gap minus 200 let's try that
out
okay great once again i'm just sort of
playing around pixels
with trial and error you'll probably
figure out the right pixel that you want
it to stop at
what looks good this looks good
don't forget to put it in brackets
however as we want this to execute as
one thing so we're going to choose
between the two
and then have and and and all the others
so
and the bad hits the bottom so there's a
game over if obstacle left is smaller
than 200
and oscar left is bigger than 280 and
about left
directly equals 220 and
either of those two and the bad bottom
deeply equals zero
cool i believe we have most our logic
done this is looking really good
i'm going to quickly go over some
styling just so we
can i can show you how to bring elements
uh
in front of one another so i'm gonna
actually make borders so
left border right border top border and
bring out the ground so our pipes are
behind all of these
so i'm gonna show you how to do that
quickly it shouldn't take too long but
it's quite a cool thing to know about
it's called the z
index so let's go ahead and add the z
index to our ground first
so by putting plus one i'm saying i want
it to be appear like
closer to us let's refresh and great it
is now in front of the pipes it is now
plus one in front of us on the z index
let's do the same for the borders so i'm
going to make a border left
once again let's make it i don't know 60
pixels wide as that is how wide our
obstacles are i'm going to give a height
of 730 pixels as that's the height of
our game container
actually i'm going to make it 90 because
if i'm going to give it about a top i
want it to
sort of be the height of the game
container and the top border
again puzzles position absolute
a background color of white so it blends
in the background
and a zen index of plus one actually
maybe
yeah plus one fine um now let's go ahead
and add this to our html
so i'm going to put this above here it
will appear stacked on top
of our game container but don't worry
we're going to give some styling to the
body of our game
oh this is very strange why are we
missing a body tag
hmm okay let's put weird let's put the
body tag in so now that we're in the
body tag
let's style up our body okay to make
sure that our
divs appear side by side and not stacked
on top of each other
so body i'm going to use display flex to
do this
cool i need to also in my game container
60 pixels left
to make space for the border left so
let's do that
let's change that to left i think that's
always felt it
let's check yeah what are left border
left and refresh
amazing we now have a border left
fantastic this is looking really good
let's go ahead and add the other two
borders
let's actually go ahead and make this
made up or a little wider
so 80 pixels here and 80 pixels here
okay that's better that's better yeah i
like that more
okay now let's make our other borders
so once again i'm gonna make a border
right
so in our html i'm gonna make a div and
give it a class of border right
cool
border right and i'm basically just
going to copy it so width
80 pixels height 790 pixels
position absolute
background color white and z index plus
two
okay now the only difference is is i'm
going to give it a left
left positioning of whatever the width
of the game container is plus the border
left width
so that's 580 pixels so it starts at the
580 pixels from the left
cool refresh amazing
now just the top one to go so the top
border it's going to be very similar
once again so
we should probably feel comfortable
doing this by now so let's go ahead and
bought a top
let's give it a width of whatever the
width is 500 plus 80 plus 80 right
because that's the border right width
and what i'm left with plus
the game width okay so
i'm actually going to put it in the game
container because i want to put it in
the game container
but i'm also going to i guess position
it outside of the game containers so
make it appear
above the sky even though it's in the
container
it's sort of not really if you get what
i mean i'm gonna make it
like position it off so yeah div class
border top okay let's save this
now border top once again width well i
guess it's going to be the border
right width and the border left with
plus the sky so 660 pixels
height let's just go with 50 pixels that
should be fine
position absolute and background color
white zed index
i guess plus two again why not okay now
this is what i mean
top i'm going to go with -50 okay
because i want it to appear above
the sky cool amazing
fantastic i am loving how our game looks
this is looking really good
i'm not going to go ahead and style off
for now that's something you could do by
yourself
i'm going to show you a little something
i made earlier so yeah this is my game
with moving grounds and everything